I
so one of the questions that I get asked
quite often by God of War fans and those
who are just familiar with the character
Kratos is whether he actually appeared
in Greek mythology or whether he was
completely made up by Santa Monica
Studios and the answer is both yes and
no the story of the craters that we know
from God of War it's not something that
was taken straight out of Greek
mythology but there was a God who went
by the name of Kratos this particular
crater sir were referring to was the son
of the Titan Pallas a deity associated
with battle and Warcraft his mother was
a Titan as sticks who is commonly
associated with both Macon Kratos was
just one of their four children his
siblings being nageire the goddess of
victory via the goddess of force
pizzelles that got of zeal and craters
himself been seen as the god of strength
and power the involvement of Kratos in
Greek myth is fairly minimal but the
role he played can still be seen as
important after Zeus and his siblings
killed their father Cronus a war between
the Olympians and the remaining Titans
began during the very beginning of this
war there were many deities who were
undecided on which side they would fight
for Styx and her children were amongst
the very first to pledge our allegiance
to Zeus and Kratos and he siblings would
turn the tide in many battles marking a
huge change in the war the only other
story that Kratos may have appeared in
is the story of Prometheus
when zoo society that Prometheus would
be punished we give Him and fire he was
destined to spend all of eternity
chained to a rock it was greater than
his siblings that were charged with
escorting a Titan to this said rock
where he would lay to be chained by
Hephaestus it's fairly difficult to save
any certainty of the crater's that
appears in Greek mythology was the
inspiration for the craters we see in
God of War but there are quite a few
factors that point to this being very
possible the Kratos in Greek mythology
may not have been a God of War but he's
far the palace was a deity associated of
Warcraft and battle and one of Kratos
his few mentions in Greek mythology was
of him taking part in a great war now I
have come across some accounts that
claim Kratos was the son of Zeus and an
unnamed woman but it's very possible
that these claims have only surfaced
because of God of War so even though we
don't really see much of Kratos in Greek
mythology we can definitely draw some
similarities between the two in order
for Santa Monica Studios to create an
entire game series based off a figure
that is mentioned so scarcely they would
have to fill in the huge gaps left
behind by traditional Greek
mythology and essentially create a
different or new character I hope this
video has helped answer any of the
questions that you guys may have had
surrounding the possible origins of
Kratos and if you're someone who
previously already knew about the gods
did you draw any similarities between
the two let me know in the comments
below
you